- Hello Believe Nation.
Today, I'm going to share with
you the best way to get a yes
from an email.
So as entrepreneurs,
we do a lot of selling
and marketing via email.
We want our emails to get open,
we want emails to be responded to,
we want people to take action,
every time we send an email out to people.
And when I was doing my
campaign for my book,
I connected with a lot of people
who were on the fringe of my network,
via email.
I've got a lot of people to
support me and take action,
and I even got one person
writing back to me saying,
"This was the single best
written request for support email
"I've ever seen."
And this guy has seen a lot.
It let me get in a
podcast interview with him
and led to a Forbes article
being written about my book,
and so it led to a lot of opportunities
all because I sent one
really well crafted email.
You guys want to see what I wrote?
I'm going to share it with you today
and hopefully you can
learn from it as well
and apply it to your business.
So as an extra point of context,
the guy wrote this too.
His name is Kevin Kruse.
I did an interview with him on my channel
over a year ago.
I had not been in touch
since.
So it's been
12 months of radio silence,
and here I was reaching out,
trying to ask for his support
in promoting my book.
Here's what I wrote.
Hi Kevin.
Thanks again for the
fun interview last year.
My fav comment was,
Incredibly good and informative video.
Thank you Evan and thank you Mister Kruse.
You have a new subscription from me.
This comes at a perfect time.
I wanted to quickly touch base
because I just launched my first book
and I could really use your help.
It's called Your One Word:
The powerful secret to creating a business
and life that matter
and I've been endorsed by Gary Vaynerchuk,
Lewis Howes, James Altucher, among others.
More can be found here.
And I link the website.
It's about finding your one
word, your one true core value,
and then building a life
and business around it,
like I have for around Believe.
I know it's going to seem greedy of me
but I was wondering what's the chance
you could help me reach more people?
It could be through an article,
a video, an introduction, or basically
anything that you think might
help spread the message.
I'm asking because I respect you
and also believe in the
message of the book so much
that anyone you connect it to
will be immediately thankful.
If not, I totally get it.
And I'm happy to support
your work in the future.
So that was the email.
I'm reading it on my phone here.
Let me break down
the different elements of it
to explain why it works so well.
So at the start, I'm just thanking him.
Thanks again for the
fun interview last year.
Kind of reminding the point of context.
He may have forgotten about me.
He may not remember who I am.
Quite often we meet so many people
in the course of a year
that it's easy to forget some people.
And so,
if you've met them at an event
or you had coffee, you
had a quick phone call,
or you've have been exchanging emails,
and it's been a long time,
just reminding them
the context of which you're reaching out,
how you guys have already met before,
or if you're being
introduced by somebody else,
putting that on their radar immediately,
so they know where you're coming from.
Next up, I share a comment.
And I did this for
everybody that I interviewed
over the past couple years on my channel.
I tried to share one good thing
to make him feel
really good.
So this person left a comment.
It was a good and informative video
thanking us, we got a new subscription.
And so, I wanted to make him feel good
about that thing that we did a year ago
reminding him about how good it was,
again, in case he forgot.
Then I wanted to get into the book
and I explained quickly what it was about.
I explained who had endorsed it,
I explained a little bit of the content
and it provided a length
more of information,
in case he cared.
I didn't want to get into
three pages long about
why the book is so great,
just a quick statement about what it is,
what it's called, who's endorsed it,
and then a link to find
out more information.
So after I introduced the book,
I wanted to ask for help.
The next line I pulled from Lewis Howes'
YouTube channel,
you have this great guy on
who's an FBI negotiator,
and this was the line
that he recommends using
in business negotiations, saying,
"I know it's going to seem greedy of me,
"but I was wondering
"what's the chance you could
help me reach more people?"
And that disarms them
and opens them up to be willing to help.
Then I was just trying to give some
examples.
So it could be through an article,
a video, an introduction,
anything that you think might
help spread the message.
I don't want to be so specific and say,
"To your newsletter list."
Because one, maybe he doesn't
have a newsletter list
or two, maybe he doesn't
want to send it out
to his newsletter list.
Basically, anything that he could think of
to help me with the book,
I would really appreciate it.
Then I flatter him a little bit, right?
I'm asking because I respect you
and also believe in the
message of the book so much
that anyone you connect it to will be
immediately thankful.
There's a lot of value in the book,
and really respect him.
And then I end on it
not being a hard sell.
So, if not, I totally get it
and I'm happy to support
your work in the future.
And so,
not forcing him to do it,
showing that I really respect
his time and his opinion,
and I'll be really
grateful for his support.
And so this really helped me
get a lot of endorsements
get a lot of support
get a lot of introductions,
get a lot of connections
and also Kevin
himself
saying that it was the single best request
for a support email he's ever seen
and that leading to his podcast interview
and the Forbes interview as well.
And so, hopefully you can
learn from that structure.
Apply it to your emails
and get a much better result
when you're sending it off to
customers, partners, investors, suppliers,
potential influences to
help get your message out.
So that's how I sell via email
with a quick template and an example.
We'll link up the text
in the description below
so you guys can copy and
paste and tweak around
like you want to.
I love to know what
did you take from this?
What did you enjoy most about this email?
Do you have any other email
secrets, tips, strategies
that you want to share?
Please leave that in the comments below.
I'm curious to find out.
Finally I want to take
up a quick shout out
to David VandenBloomen Junior.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really, means a lot to me.
And I hope you're enjoying it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I Believe in you.
I hope you continue to Believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love,
I'll see you soon.